my name is peter santaniello and i make
videos around
the world but for the first time i'm
showing my home country
america in this video series my
ukrainian wife and i travel through
northern california
to places most foreigners and even
americans don't know about
we will show you usa culture through the
combination of an outsiders
and a local's perspective join us on a
road trip through a very diverse
often misunderstood and stunningly
beautiful land
it's really cool when you come back to
your country after being gone for a long
time
so guys got a different type of video
for you
usually my content's out in the world
but this time it's in my home country on
my home turf
so in this series we're gonna go through
the places i spent a lot of my adult
life
in this the places that are special to
me
so this road trip is northern california
and i brought
nana nana gutter us visa
and we're road tripping for the next
what two weeks
eight days nine days something like that
yeah so this is for you guys to my
audience
to those that have just found this
channel i want to show you
in my opinion some of the most beautiful
interesting parts of america
coming up on donner pass the honor pass
is named after the donner party
who what was it 1846 and seven i believe
right they were going
to california and they got caught
did you know this babe no okay they got
caught
by an early snowstorm in these mountains
in the sierra nevadas they couldn't get
the horses and carriages
over this pass
so they resorted to cannibalism they ate
each other
many ate the weak and the sick just to
survive through
the winter downgrade 40 miles
so we're at the top of the sierra crest
in the winter tons of snow here
40 miles palm trees
and relative warm
what's going on with modern hip-hop
culture
they have very refined samples and beads
like this is a very nice one it's like a
masterpiece
like a fine art one of my favorite
places
used to come down here all the time my
younger 20s to get out of the snow
because i lived up at lake tahoe at
elevation in the winter
cold snowing and then you just drop
drop drop down the mountain and when you
get to nevada city it's only at like i
think 2 000 feet in elevation
uh 700 meters so it's for the most part
below the snow line
and everything changes like the
the fauna the flora the whole look of
the place
that's where we're going to end up
tonight
it's cool huh
i'm forgetting where the fall is i can't
believe it but i'm forgetting
going to washington not the state
not the capital but washington
california
and so guys this is a very interesting
little town
so we're going to go off the main
highway the main road highway 20.
we're basically on a ridge so it drops
down into a valley with the yuba river
at the bottom
but washington when i was here last
it's this somewhat lawless feeling place
and so way before weed was
was legal in california to buy
dispensaries and wherever
and washington they were selling on the
streets to be like guys set up with
tables
just selling bricks of weed on the
street the cops
would come down sorry cop would come
down here
once a month and so it's just sort of
this lawless
rogue type of place far removed from
everything
no cell phone coverage and people just
seem to get
stuck down here like they'd come down to
washington gravity would bring them down
and then they'd
never come back up this hill i got stuck
down here
one night my car broke down coming out
of washington
almost to the top this hill we're on now
and then it broke down i had to coast
all the way back and
stayed at this old hotel creepy
haunted feeling got drunk with a bunch
of locals
and well this is sort of that wild west
feel and even though we're in california
people think san francisco los angeles
california has so many parts where
you're totally removed like you're super
far from everything
it's very wild it's a huge state
so washington's one of these cool places
and let's see if it's changed at all
says no fireworks because it is so dry
that one dropped cigarette or a firework
look at that truck babe we'll just set
this place on fire
you like that um well
natalia likes these pickups she likes
the pickups
yeah because it's so different doesn't
happen
population 166. and here's the
washington hotel
this is where i stayed want to check it
out
why not let's check it out
this is some true americana down here
huh
harley davidson monster trucks look at
that place
yeah beware of the dog is a common
sign in america did you know that no
beware of dog it means like you you
should not enter this it means like
exactly okay
she's a little out of place here oh they
have a dog
muffin why is there something hanging
in the porch [ __ ] if i know
what are your first feelings of
washington
it's just so stale oh it's got the
american
coffee pot museum for coffee pot lovers
largest coffee pot museum west of the
mississippi
wow this
is cool this is really interesting
hello how are you doing good
beautiful place washington yes it is
you're from here well let's say
i've been coming up here for 67 years
has it changed much no no nothing
not too much are they pretty much the
same people living here as did before
well yeah but a lot of us have passed
away ah
but they keep on getting new more there
were more people in here
it's like um it's very uh relaxed here
huh
yeah nothing's going on no that's why we
moved here
yeah it's like the opposite of uh
los angeles yeah i lived down there for
a while and i worked as a sea rock taper
and i
i don't like the sand and i don't like
the ocean
i want to see green trees and i want to
see water i can
look were you two from los angeles
no i'm from ukraine ukraine oh yeah
hello dear
long ways yeah do they make all the
women pretty like you
oh send something down to little
washington park yeah let's bring some
woman down to washington
let's do it ukrainization i'm
sure you can find some old miners that
would just love to be able to right take
them to the american coffee pot
museum down to the river yeah little
gold mining
yeah yeah do they still pan for gold
down here
well in certain areas you can but some
of you can't
okay you can go up the second bridge and
go to golden courts and you
you can you can pan up there with no
problem but everybody else has like
a claim and that stuff so it's really
gotcha
what's your name i'm snake snake peter
pleasure to meet you pleasure to meet
you natalia
yes got it right take care
yeah thank you thanks snake
so this is one of the old mining carts
they would be on you know be on tracks
and they'd take the
minerals out the rocks whatever else
let's go in love i'm sure you'll make
some friends very quickly
old school hello doing well
just cruising just cruising and checking
stuff out oh
i need something to drink
cool
so clean i want to jump in how cool is
snake
exactly did you record it
yeah yeah the whole time i've been
recording for eight minutes
[Music]
we got offered weed twice already right
oh look at the doggo
ah it's a little bit scary maybe let's
get in the car
yeah california is the california dream
you're thinking of there's a confederate
flag
some interesting music going on and
let's not get the
let's go hello hi
nice truck you drinking budweiser yeah
nice my ex-wife worked for a bird
your ex-wife worked for budweiser yeah
so
actually a drinking bud and you got the
like the bar
light in your window and you see that
yeah does that go on at night yeah it
[Applause]
worked
i love these these rivers i grew up
doing this
jumping bridges into water halls
hanging out hot summer days there's a
nice sound
so clean
this is what i miss the most i would say
[Music]
so check this out it's like an old
motel oh there's that place that's
beautiful like each room yeah each room
is different okay
but like that's very american right that
motel theme where you drive up
to your room but they took this and made
them all
super nice
there you go
cool huh
where's the light switch
rustic theme camping theme they were
trying to
create the feeling check this out
got like a little back zone area dried
up creek
i love the porches yeah like the classic
porches everywhere
so nevada city is at the foothills of
the sierra nevada mountains
which means when the gold rush happened
in 1849
well this place was awash
with money and that's why a lot of these
places
look so cool because they had
money to do it right and tomorrow we're
gonna go right
up into the hills here and uh see some
of the old gold mining operations
so i guess this is i mean california
pretty much was
somewhat empty and then 1849 happened
and
everyone came to make their fortunes
so it was the risk takers it was those
that wanted
the adventure the unknown the potential
to make a ton of coin
and this is one of those cities
where it was happening
i love the detail look at that handle
so cute look at this place
so we're at about 2 000 feet so
what is that 700 meters and when i lived
up in
tahoe that's 6 200 feet 2000 meters
and come down here in the winter and it
was green
without any snow and somewhat warm
there's some scattered palm trees
and i love that about this region is
that you can
be in a ton of snow full on winter
drive an hour and 20 minutes and be in
somewhere completely
different that's what's special about
this part of the country to me
right babe isn't that cool today we
started in the desert basically
mountains foothills
yeah everything's different look at that
this is the church in the trees there
see that in the trees yes that's a
church
and someone turned it into a home
it is amazing
no seriously it is it's beautiful it's
nothing that i was thinking of
what were you thinking of um well nevada
i started
it's a desert so sort of desert
look at this
desert like yeah nothing like this
yeah it's a special place
what do you think of the size of these
portions no no i love it
um
i need to figure out the way of moving
with the camera
you're so bitter i look beat up huh
i feel like i screamed it up
[Music]
was
just shoot out into the mountain this is
what made a lot of people
rich take a look
wow looks amazing it's the rv of the
it's like a hipster barber shop
you